طب من يعيشكم كيف الحال اهلا وين موقعك
الان
انا موقعي الان في تونس العاصمه في المنزل
السادس طيب من المنزله السادس ايش ودى
القرش قرش الغرد الغردقه الى تونس ايش
القصه
قرش الغردقه في الحادثه الاليمه للاسف
التي وقعت في مصر نتمنى السلامه لجميع
الاحبابنا المصريين وصل سداه الى تونس هنا
على شبكات السوشيال ميديا كل التوانسه على
الفيسبوك وانستجرام سيقضون السيف تحت
المكيف لماذا بسبب الخوف من القرش الذي
كما قلنا ارتدادات هذا الخبر وصلت الى
تونس هنا التوانسه خائفين من تكرار هذا
الحدث هنا في السواحل التونسيه لكن علماء
الاحياء تدخلوا واكدوا بان الشواطئ
التونسيه امنه صحيح ان هناك قرابه 40 نوع
من القرش تعيش داخل البحر المتوسط وموجوده
على السواحل التونسيه لكنها لن تصل الى
الشاطئ بسبب عديد الظروف المناخيه وطبيعه
البحر المتوسط الذي لا يشبه البحر الاحمر
وكذلك طبيعه عموم
في تونس التي تفرق عن السواحل البحر
الاحمر المصريه فحسم العلماء الجدل
وبامكان التوانسه ان يغادروا المكيف نحو
البحار اذا اطمنوا ايها التونسيون وكل من
يريد ان يقضي الصيف على شواطئ البحر
المتوسط الجميله
طيب موضوع اخر حاجه مميزه تونسيه هذه
المره شو قصتها شو عندك يا احلام
104 من السنوات قضتها وهي تنتظر الحاجه
التونسيه بان تزور الكعبه المشرفه وان
تذهب الى الحج تحققت اخيرا بعد هذه الرحله
الطويله من العمر توجهت هذه الحاجه اسيره
قصور السيف من محافظه المهديه يوم الاثنين
الفارت الى البقاع المقدسه لاداء فطيره
فريضه الحاج عفوا وبهكذا تعتبر هي الحاجه
المراه الاكبر سنا التي زارت الكعبه
المشرفه وقامت بمناسك الحج حدث شد
الانتباه وكذلك تداولته هنا بقوه وسائل
الاعلام والسوشيال ميديا التحقق العلوم
بعد كل هذا العمر الله يتقبل منها ان شاء
الله صالح الاعمال ويكتب لها هذه طبعا
باذن الله شكرا جزيلا احلام العبد الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات